welcome to the Napa Valley Film Festival
what is your what's your favorite thing
about wine country I told my producers I
was gonna be mad if she didn't say wine
when asked what favorite thing that was
so beautiful here like what where are we
and it's full of nature now tell me I
caught a picture on your Instagram of
you and your mom which was adorable is
this a girls trip for you yeah you guys
have a car about it a while ago and I
was like so sweet it's the best I love
having her around she's just a burst of
sunshine and like instantly everyone's
mother so I'm like I come as myself but
also as a mother for you all you must be
so proud she must be so proud of you
you're being recognized as a visionary
that's a big title how does that make
you feel
like are you sure they that's that's for
me I'm sure it's for you I'm 100%
positive everybody's don't know I mean
that's that's an absolute honor I just I
love what I do when I get to do it all
the time and I feel like it's just a
really exciting moment of time for me as
well cuz I've never been so busy in my
life yeah and it shows that you love
what you do and I think that's something
that the festival recognizes is that you
love what you do you're visionary you
take risks and you do all that stuff
when you when you happen to a role do
you ever think I'm doing this to to
entertain or be an entertainer do you
remember the first time you wanted to
entertain how about that oh good well
we'd have to go back to like
four-year-old Vanessa really yeah I I
just loved performing like you some
people call themselves actresses some
call themselves musicians I call myself
like a performer because I grew up doing
musical theater and being on the stage
and embodying other characters is how I
felt comfortable as a functioning member
of society you know so that's just
always been my thing all right now I'm
gonna I'm gonna do a little ET flashback
with you have a clip here I love a blast
bag just from 2004 your very first et
Interpol look at this oh my god it's not
every day you get to be a rescue hero
it's just amazing to see like girls get
to do rescuing to Angelina Jolie Tomb
Raider mmm yes she Angelina Jolie and to
mater it's just incredible what she does
jumping off these buildings and under
girl that's what happens when you don't
wash your face oh boy so that's pretty
that is your message to that to that
version of yourself what do you think of
when you see that girl oh my gosh I'm
like she's trying so hard to be the
professional one because it's like
you're I would think I was 14 or 15 oh I
don't know 2004 very yeah but I applaud
myself for how together I had it you
know like that goes along with the
performer thing like you put me in an in
a circumstance and I'm gonna act that
part I love it why I if I'm like in a
place like nap I need to be wearing a
napa outfit I need to be wearing another
major jacket the producers you take it
I'm gonna follow that clip up with one
more foot because I'm just resting the
peace and never let's get this other one
up now this is from 2007 okay that's the
musical - yes I really want to be an
action hero recently though I've been
working on the gym and I see myself like
kicking everyone's butt like it's my
inspiration because that's actually the
thing that I say still to this day like
I can't work out on my own I need to be
in a class where I can be better than
everyone who do you who do you look at
now you talk about Angelina Jolie talk
about playing an action star I can look
at now as a role model in the industry
or somebody playing a role what my goals
were and keep talking about myself and
say yes girl you wanted to do action and
now you're in the next bad boys like
dreams do come true when bad boys for
life
yeah perfect segue Vanessa thank you I
love this interview talk to me about how
you fit into the bad boys universe I'm
born and raised in Miami I grew up I
love I read that question super happy
about it talk to me a little bit about
bad boys what was it like on that set oh
my gosh well I play Kelly she's a new
part of the ammo team which is the new
squad that gets brought on to work with
Willa Martin
and they're just amazing like Martin is
such a sweetheart he's always just so
kind and warm and welcoming and like
tender obviously and then will is just
like a burst of energy like he's full of
life he's full of love
they were like sending gifts to my
trailer like on the weekly you know it's
like this is not normal this is just too
sweet there's nothing better that I
could hear about my favorite action
movie franchise from what you just said
thank you
oh the karaoke bit which was amazing by
the way
okay talk to me about this amazing video
you stole the Internet you literally
grabbed the internet you put in your
pocket hasn't come out yet you're
singing break but talk to me you sang
breaking free you look like you had the
time of your life oh yeah yes I was it
was just I did this independent film and
it was a tiny little bubble that we
created and we were all like family and
that was my last night that I was gonna
be with everyone so I put on a little
vintage dress that I had bought in town
and proceeded to sing karaoke the entire
night because it was my last night and I
had sang a little bit I sang Evanescence
and everyone was screaming wait up we
need to see those videos but the karaoke
it was just yeah it was a moment a girl
came up to me and she was like um
Vanessa another girl and she's like you
know my go-to karaoke song like what she
said breaking free and I was like we
should sing it together so it happened
and whenever you feel like handing the
internet back its life just let us know
now tell me a little bit about the night
before Christmas your Netflix movie
coming out first about that it's really
sweet it's really great I I love a time
travel movie elf is like one of my
favorite Christmas film
and it's just a really sweet story about
like a woman who has been hurt by love
and ends up falling in love with someone
that her mind can't even wrap her head
around how he's here so it's definitely
just kind of a place to suspend belief
and like believe in the magic of love
set in the holiday time is a great pitch
I'm ready to be in front of a Christmas
tree watching your movie that's
Sotomayor place yes and my jacket
problem this way I'll be able to wear it
by this
[Music]